i don't like it like one day one day
you'll be like 70 and you'll be like
begging people to shoot their shot
but that's like how guys i don't need it
that's how guys do it like as much as
possible until like yeah hands on
someone
that's
how they do it like they wouldn't they
wouldn't do it if it didn't work
sometimes
yeah i guess
like how did you and your boyfriend get
together how did he approach it we met
at a games night and he said hello right
and we said and we just started chatting
with someone asking it was that i
started a conversation no because i
don't even actually remember how the
conversation started we were in a group
setting and someone said something and
someone else said something else
and that's how it like no one was like
oh you look cute oh yeah okay so if
you're if your boyfriend came up to you
and said you look very nice this is like
i'm whatever his name is
he wouldn't you wouldn't
if he came up with him like you look
very nice no no he says that like in a
nice way so you like like he gave you a
compliment yeah you would be offended i
wouldn't be offended but i feel like if
you're just randomly muttering things at
me as i'm walking through the streets i
feel like why well he doesn't have to
randomly mutter but you know what i mean
that's what that's what my situation is
but i'm saying like
like this is why guys say women are
confusing and they don't like nice guys
that's true but do you think it's nice
to be like okay absolutely
if you're walking down the street
i'll tell you my theory on this and this
this is this is a theory in progress
it's kind of weak well i i think of it
as emotional magnification so like i
have this idea that and i'm still this
is this is a weak theory but women like
to feel as emotional about things as
possible right they want to avoid logic
because if you can explain something
simply then it's not it's not arousing
emotionally you can't be aroused about
like maths or physics however if you get
a compliment from someone that's
positive then you can then choose like
whatever narrative in your head feminist
narrative and say now i get to feel
offended and then when you transmit that
story you can then add another dimension
to it so you can add as many different
dimensions so that's that's my view of
why women tend to make very simple
things as intense and like dramatic as
possible because they rather feel than
think
but to me it's uncomfortable if some if
i'm walking behind someone it makes me
feel uncomfortable but you're in control
of your emotions you should be anyway i
am
make you feel uncomfortable yeah yeah
but that's what i'm saying like you can
just say okay and then mind you like go
on with your day but you're choosing to
let it get to you it's a choice but i'm
like i'm allowed to not like it you're
allowed to not like it but i'm saying
like you're choosing to focus on it okay
let me ask you a question if you dress
up you wear you've gone you got no money
you put your best dress on your best
makeup and you go outside and for the
whole day not one single person give you
a compliment how do you feel
even the people that you know
not one single person i don't know i
just wouldn't care
what if it happened for about a week or
something in a month you have so much
caps
like need to be right type yeah this is
need to be right like in action
but like i just i don't know i just
wouldn't care
like how how are men supposed to know
how to approach women
like how are they supposed to know what
each woman likes to be approached and
doesn't like to be approached i guess
you can feel it
no you can tell by like energy you know
you can feel it notice can you not tell
by like energy you can feel it okay no
english
man i just have a question can you can
you just feel it yeah you can't
absolutely not i thought enough
i thought nothing i said hello i made a
compliment i gave you a compliment and i
tried to escalate to like a meeting and
that failed horribly most of the time so
telling me that there's a feeling
it's it's no it's so and it's like
confusing to men because you're out here
getting offended i'm like i love the
compliments keep going and so it's like
man it's the thing it's not really it's
two different people but you can feel
that way and that's fine there's nothing
wrong with the way you feel and there's
nothing wrong with the way i feel it's
just that
it's just everyone's different but i'm
saying
okay
this is this is the whole post-modern
thing that's going on now that people
feel that they're entitled to their own
version of reality so i can feel any way
about anything and technically that's a
valid point of view so i used to i used
to have this opinion in university where
like you know i was quite popular in my
final year of university i i figured it
out in my uni when i was like these guys
for the [ __ ] i'm just gonna i'm just
gonna do this and so i'll talk to these
girls take them out on like you know
semi dates and they'll be in my room and
things would escalate from there and i
would just watch how each one would
approach it so some of them were cool
but some of them would be in the room
and they were awkward but when women are
awkward they try and make you feel
awkward so that because they're they're
in the strong position right so there
was this one girl in my bed under my
sheets
cheeks on me and then she was like just
because i'm here doesn't mean i want to
have sex and i was like sorry
no i literally grilled her on this i was
like she's actually a long time this is
what made her my friend because i was
like hold on so so what are we doing why
are you why are you under my sheets
right now she was like well maybe you
know it doesn't have to be about sex
then why are you on under my sheets why
is your butt on my groin right now
the point being showing bedtime story
that
there is no like separate version of
reality you're entitled to see there are
social norms and there are kind of
things where behaviors are appropriate
behaviors expected and behaviors are
incorrect
so that that's like do you know the
privilege you have to be able to
complain when people compliment you
what do you mean
what do i mean do you know the privilege
that you have to be able to complain
when people compliment you
like being getting complimented is a
privilege you're a pretty girl not
everybody gets compliments there's fat
chick there's whales every day that go
unnoticed i hate that don't come in
wales but that's what they are no
they're not it's what they are not what
am i supposed to call someone that's
over 300 pounds that's just all who they
are i will
what what would you call them
she's a human being that's a whale she's
not like
i could be on my days
now they'll put her on the cover of
cosmo we'll call it beautiful
maybe she's to who she is to who to who
to whoever's looking at her like i don't
feel like you have to be a certain size
to be beautiful i don't feel yeah i feel
okay i don't think
that you have to be a certain size
to be beautiful you do not yeah you
don't but i think so but there's reality
and there's okay there's because you
look the way you look there's this many
guys knocking on your door if you were
300 pounds there'd be a lot less guys
knocking on your door
it depends what guys i'm into you know
depends if they're like a chunky girl no
it's true
i grew up i grew up fat and then i lost
weight and i was like super skinny okay
and it was actually getting annoying how
many guys were coming up to me now that
i've gained weight again
i'm like oh chill i like it this way
i personally don't like
people bothering me
but i'm not gonna blame them for trying
i'm just like okay you tried chill just
don't touch me
and don't like hurt me that's it it's
fine i'm coming for some asian woman
absolutely
if they don't harass you i just do not
see the problem but a lot of them do
harass you and this is why women call
harassment everything like women call
women are like the biggest softies when
it comes to harassment like none of
y'all have been really harassed okay i
go i'll give i'll give you a couple
compliments and maybe maybe he'll keep
going with it they'll be like oh my god
harassment i'm like he just complimented
you a couple times let me give you an
example okay okay so
one day i live the tube is here so i've
got two tube stations where i live right
so there's one here literally next to
the apartments i live by and there's one
over there